[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JASON TITUS: Good
morning, everyone.
I'm Jason, and I lead
the Developer Product
Group at Google.
I'm so excited to be
here with all of you
at Google Developer Days Europe.
This region is an amazing
one for technology,
with startup hubs blossoming
across the continent,
from London to Paris
to Berlin and Warsaw.
The talent here is incredible.
In fact, a few years
ago, when I was
the CTO at Shazam
in London, we would
hire from across the continent.
Some of our best
developers came from Spain
and Greece and Germany
and Lithuania and Poland.
And fast forward to
today, and Europe
has more developers than
the United States and Canada
combined.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE]
JASON TITUS: Which is
why it's really exciting
to have Google
Developer Days here
so that we can meet and
work with all of you.
We want to give
you what you need
to turn your ideas into
reality, whether you're
building a mobile app or
using new technologies like AR
or machine learning.
We want to enable you
to focus on the problems
you're trying to solve
and minimize the pain
points of building a product.
And in addition to building
products to help you succeed,
we're also working on
building out trainings
to deepen your technical
capabilities year round.
Today, I'm happy to share that
we've opened our mobile web
certification that will enable
you to further expand your web
skills.
And on the ground, our team is
working in over 130 countries.
And within Europe, we've
reached over 185,000 developers
just this year through
local events and programs.
We have in Europe over 200
developer experts, many of whom
are in this room today, who
are sharing their expertise.
And we're continuing to
expand the developer ecosystem
through programs such as
Women Techmakers, the Google
Developer Agency Program, and
our Google Developer groups.
Last year, we started our
Launchpad Accelerator program,
which connects top
startups with mentors
and brings them
to Silicon Valley
to meet with Google
product leads.
In our fourth class, we had
our first startup from Poland.
These three entrepreneurs
recognized the need
to provide therapy at scale
for autistic children.
In response, they
created DrOmnibus,
an app-based learning
platform that
provides games for children
with special education needs.
The game allows students
to learn behavior patterns
and responses to
real-life scenarios.
And their teachers
and therapists
can review their progress.
The best part is that
students can play these games
on their own, allowing them
to get therapy every day,
rather than once a
week, which makes
an incredible impact long term.
This is just one of many stories
of how the European development
community is making
a big impact.
Now I'd like to bring
up some of my colleagues
to share updates across
our developer platforms.
And let's start with how we're
making the Android development
process easier.
Please welcome Dan.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL GALPIN: Thank you, Jason.
It is the best time ever
to be an Android developer.
Now I've been developing for
Android for almost nine years,
and I've spent seven of
those years at Google.
But I've never seen anything
like what we have now--
this incredible confluence of
meaningful developer changes.
We're seeing ever more powerful
tooling, a clear path forward
for app design, a new
programming language,
and fundamental improvements
to the distribution model.
And much of this change derives
from listening to all of you
in the developer community.
And all of this is happening
amidst the incredible momentum
that Android continues to have.
I mean, we're seeing 2 billion
active devices on Android
and 82 billion apps
installed from Play.
And what's even more amazing
is how this momentum is making
so many developers successful.
The number of developers
with over a million installs
grew 35% in the past year.
Now to leverage
this distribution
to build great businesses, we
expanded direct-carrier billing
to reach 900 million devices
with over 140 operators.
And altogether, the number
of people buying on Play
grew by almost 30%
this past year.
But that's not enough.
We know that we can make
distribution even better
by removing the friction
from app installs
and making the entire
experience more dynamic.
So Instant Apps is
one of our big bets
in bringing more
users to your apps,
and our early partners
are seeing great results.
Onefootball, based
in Berlin, saw
that the number of users who
read news and shared content
increased 55% in
their Instant App,
while Vimeo increased their
session durations by 130%.
Jet found that the conversion
rate in their shopping app
increased by 27%.
And there are many more
stories like these.
At I/O, we opened up
Android Instant Apps
to all Android developers,
which means anyone can now build
and publish an Instant App.
Since then, we've made Instant
Apps available to more than 500
million Android devices
across countries
where Google Play operates.
Your Instant App is downloaded
as needed, feature by feature.
And you enable this by
organizing your project
into feature modules.
And then you can use that exact
same code in both your Instant
App and your installable app.
We're easing the process
of refactoring your app
into these feature modules
by using the new Modularize
refactoring action.
And Modularize helps you
move code and resources
between modules.
We've also included
optimization tools,
from space-shaving
shared libraries
to more efficient
asset delivery,
to on-the-wire compression.
So when you're ready, you just
upload your Instant App APKs,
together with your installable
APK into Play Console.
To get started building
in Instant App today,
visit g.co/instantapps.
All right, so since you're
here, you probably heard
our exciting news from
I/O. And that, of course,
is that we're now offering
first-class support
for the Kotlin programming
language in Android.
And Kotlin support is now
built into Android Studio.
So--
[APPLAUSE]
So obviously, I don't have to
tell you this-- why Kotlin?
And that's because the
community really wanted it.
Kotlin is a mature production
lab-ready language that's
been around for five years.
And so we investigated.
And people at investigating
became Kotlin champions.
As developers,
languages are the tools
that we use to
express our thoughts.
And with Kotlin, there's just
so much less syntactic noise
between what I want to
say and how I say it.
And since our announcement
at Google I/O,
Kotlin has been
growing like crazy.
It's really a fantastic
programming language,
and it's great to see so many
of you out there adopting it.
But to be clear, we
have added Kotlin
as an additional language.
We're not replacing the Java
programming language or C++.
And we support building
apps with as much Kotlin
as you want, from 0% to 100%.
And in fact, it operates 100%
with the Java programming
language.
That means you can
keep every line of code
that you have in your
existing code base.
And you can seamlessly call
from Kotlin into the Java
programming language and back.
And you can get started
by adding as little
as a single Kotlin class.
And JetBrains, who
we've partnered with
to provide Kotlin
support for Android,
are here and giving a
talk on Kotlin today.
So please swing by to learn
more if you haven't already.
Now minimizing install
friction with Instant Apps
and the support of the
Kotlin programming language
are just two of the
ways in which we've
listened to your feedback.
We've also learned you want
faster, easier development,
with better tools and libraries.
So Android Studio
is our official IDE,
purpose-built for Android.
And we keep increasing
our investment.
At Google I/O, we launched the
preview for Android Studio 3.0,
focusing on speed and
smarts and platform support,
plus new libraries
for app architecture.
And this is going to migrate
to stable release soon.
[CHUCKLES] And based
on your feedback,
you can see all the
speed and smarts updates
we've made to Android
Studio behind me.
But I do want to call out
one thing in particular.
Your feedback has
made driving down sync
and build time our
number one priority.
So benchmarking with a
real-life 100-module project,
since 2.2, build config
time dropped from 3 minutes
to 2 seconds.
And we're continuing to
work on build performance.
And for me super exciting,
on the emulators,
we added the Play Store
for end-to-end testing.
So next, we'll talk about
Android platform support.
We recently unveiled our latest
dessert name for Android.
And you'll find awesome features
for Android Oreo in Android
Studio, like end-to-end
Instant App support,
Oreo system images,
improve profilers, and tons
of Oreo helper
tools, like a tool
to make building
adaptive icons easy.
And to download Android
dependencies for your build,
you don't have to go through
the SDK manager any more.
We're now distributing through
our own Maven repository.
Finally, you've asked us to
make Android Frameworks easier,
like providing an opinionated
guide for best practices
and a better solution
for life cycles.
So at I/O, we launched a
preview of new Architecture
Components-- libraries
for common tasks.
And this starts with libraries
with a view model pattern,
data storage, and managing
activity and fragment life
cycles.
And soon, we'll be announcing
support for paging, which
will make it easier
to use Recycler View,
(WHISPERING) which is awesome.
App-- yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Very excited about that.
So app quality is
an essential piece
to growing a
successful business.
And we took a sample
of apps, and we
analyzed the correlation
between app quality and business
success.
And what we learned is
when apps move from average
to good quality, we see a
sixfold increase in spend
and a seven-fold
increase in retention.
Quality is queen.
Now your app
quality might differ
depending on the type of
device it's running on.
So to help you ensure that
you're targeting devices that
work best for your app, you
can now target specific devices
in the Play Console.
You can browse a
detailed device--
yeah, isn't this [INAUDIBLE]?
It's awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
We've been waiting
for that forever.
You can browse a
detailed device catalog,
and if you need a
certain amount of RAM,
or if you have issues with a
particular system on System
Chip, you can set tarting
rules to address this as well.
And prior to
excluding devices, you
can even see your installs,
your ratings, and your revenue
details per device.
Now we've got Android Vitals
Dashboards in the Play Console.
So you can see aggregate
data about your map
to help you pinpoint common
issues, like excessive crash
rates, ANR rates, frozen
frames, slow rendering,
excessive wake-ups, and more.
And these are enhanced
by improved profilers
in Android Studio and
new instrumentation
in the platform.
Whew.
Speaking of the platform,
Android O ads so much
for developers, such as
vastly improved font support,
an auto-sizing text view,
notification channels,
and a new native pro-audio API.
We've made massive
improvements in the runtime,
including a concurrent
copying collector
and a series of optimizations
to make your apps run smoother
than ever.
We've introduced adaptive
icons to improve the Launcher
experience and continued
to harden Android security,
with Google Play
Protect now enabled
on every device
with Google Play.
We've improved
accessibility, added support
for Autofill and
SmarTech Selection,
added support for a
wide gamut of color
and extra long screens, and
improved multi-display support.
And I'll be diving into
all of this and much more
in detail later today.
But let's talk about
some of the ways
we're extending the
Android platform.
Last week, we announced
and launched ARCore.
Now--
[APPLAUSE]
--ARCore is a platform for
building augmented-reality apps
on Android.
And it uses three
key technologies
to integrate virtual
content with the real world,
as seen through
your phone's camera.
So you've got motion
tracking to allow the phone
to understand and track its
position relative to the world.
We've got environmental
understanding,
which allows the phone
to detect the size
and location of flat
or long services,
like the ground
or a coffee table.
And light estimation
allows the phone
to estimate the environment's
current lighting conditions.
Now this is being offered
as an early preview.
So you can start experimenting
with and building new AR
experiences.
And this is also an
opportunity for you
to get feedback on an
early version of the API.
And this preview
is the first step
in a journey to
enabling AR capabilities
across the entire
Android ecosystem.
So check out the Documentation
pages to learn more.
All right, switch gears,
literally, to Android Auto.
It's still early days, but
we're seeing incredible growth.
We continue to expand the number
of Android Auto-compatible cars
through great partnerships
with over 50 car brands.
And there are over 300
Android Auto-compatible models
and aftermarket systems
available today.
And that's triple the
number from one year ago.
And it's well on its way to
becoming a standard feature
in every new car.
And we've also made Android Auto
available to all Android users
with a standalone phone
app, opening up the platform
and ecosystem to many
millions of drivers,
no matter what kind of
car they're driving.
Whether you're looking to
stay connected with WhatsApp
or Allo, pass the time
with a Player.fm podcast
or the latest album
releases on Spotify,
we've got great apps
on Android Auto.
And it's usage is
growing rapidly as well,
but this is just the beginning.
We're working with
two European partners
in automotive electronics
infotainment, Audi and Volvo,
on vehicle infotainment
systems powered by Android.
And we're really excited
to partner with them
to usher in the future
of connected cars.
Now voice input is critical
in the car for safety reasons.
And the Google
Assistant can provide
that intelligent and
conversational voice
as we move from a mobile first
world to an AI first world.
And we want it to
be the best copilot
for the user in the car.
So on your road, your assistant
can tell you about traffic
ahead, or show you gas
stations along the way,
or play your favorite song.
And many of these
experiences are
only possible because
developers like you
are implementing the right API.
So thank you for helping
us create a great user
experience on Android Auto.
All right, let's go
to the living room.
Android TV is seeing
amazing device growth.
Our strong partnerships with
pay-TV operators and hardware
manufacturers allowed
us to double the number
of activated devices in 2016.
And we expect that trend to
continue and further increase.
We're seeing this both across
partners in the set-top box
and in the smart-TV
form factors, including
the many European solutions
powered by Android TV.
And we've expanded our
international footprint
to 70 countries.
And there are now
more than 3,000 apps
in the Android TV Play Store.
But the real Android
TV story is the way
we've redefined the experience.
This new homescreen is
channel-based and content
first.
It's divided into channel rows,
each created by a media app
to display a window of program
content relevant to you.
And selecting that
program takes you
right into that
content in the app.
You can see what
On Demand shows you
need to finish binge
watching, what's on your DVR,
and what movies you might want
to rent, On in the same view.
We've also updated
the set-up experience
to allow you to easily
transition media apps
from other Android devices.
And we've made big updates
to the Leanback Library,
such as the Playback
element, which
adds detailed Seek thumbnails.
And of course, we've integrated
the Google Assistant,
which allows you to search,
launch video content,
and then dim the lights
when you want to watch,
all using your voice.
All right, let's switch to
something a little bit closer--
Android Wear.
During the holiday period
last year, Android Wear
saw 72% growth.
And that was before we
launched Android Wear 2.0.
The number of brands
supporting Android Wear
doubled from 12 last year to 24.
And the choice of
Android Wear watches
doubled from 23 last year to 46.
And Wear is enabling
fashionable watches
from European partners such
as the Connected Modular
45 from Tag Heuer, the Montblanc
Summit, and the Louis Vuitton
Tambour Horizon, and along
with a multitude of styles,
like from partners across
many price points and brands.
And apps are taking
advantage of Android Wear
2.0 and its standalone
functionality.
So this app from our
partner Telegram,
works the same if you're
connected to an Android
phone or an iPhone, or if your
watch has a cellular connection
without the phone at all.
Sending stickers to your
friends has never been easier.
Another feature we
added to Android Wear
2.0, Complications,
allows watch faces
to display extra information
without needing code
for getting the underlying data.
Users select the watch
face that they want,
with the most
important information
they really care about.
And it's available at a
glance throughout the day.
So here, Robinhood, the
financial investment app,
is showing you your
overall portfolio's value.
Tapping on it then takes
you to your watch list.
And you can tap on individual
stocks to see their values.
Finally, as part of the
Android Wear 2.0 launch,
we announced the Google
Assistant is now on your wrist,
enhancing [INAUDIBLE]
voice capabilities.
So going forward, apart from
Notifications, Watch Faces,
and Native Apps, you
will have another option
to bring this service
to Android Wear
when we enable Actions
on Google for Wear.
And we're excited about the new
capabilities this will bring.
All right, with so
many ways for people
to interact with Android,
the strong communities that
are supporting Android
development, the improvements
that we've made in the
platform, tooling, language,
and in the distribution
of Google Play,
it really is the best time ever
to be an Android developer.
So please check out the
sessions, the trainings,
and the code labs here to learn
how we're helping developers
make Android great.
Now all of the
Android form factors
are tapping into the power
of the Google Assistant.
So it's my pleasure to welcome
my colleague Tilke to the stage
to talk about what the Google
Assistant means to developers.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TILKE JUDD: Thanks, Dan.
Hi, everyone.
As you just heard,
the Google Assistant
is now available across many
devices, from your phone,
to your car, to
your watch, and TV.
It is also available
on Google Home
and all of the devices powered
by the Google Assistant SDK.
Tomorrow, you'll hear more
about these from my colleague
Behshad, who will talk about the
improvements on the Assistant
on these devices.
But today, I want to focus
on what you as developers can
do to bring the power of the
Assistant to your own apps.
With the Assistant now
available across devices,
you have the opportunity to grow
your user base in a new way.
But more importantly,
you can build
apps for entirely new
assistive use cases.
Things that previously
weren't suited
for the Voice Only
interface of Google Home,
like shopping for
clothes or ordering food
from a lengthy menu
With UI elements,
like image carousels,
lists, and suggestion tips,
users can see more details.
They can also
seamlessly transition
between voice, typing, or
taps in a single conversation
to easily get things
done with your app.
We also want to help
you grow your business
by making it easy to complete
purchases through the Google
Assistant.
We designed the
Transactions experience
to be easy and lightweight for
users and developers alike.
For Payments, available
in Europe soon,
you can choose
Google-facilitated payments.
They are easy to integrate and
allow you to leverage cards
that users have already
stored with Google for free.
Or you can use a payment
method the user has already
provided you.
You can use seamless
account linking
to enable users to sign
into an existing account
or even create a new
account with just two taps.
But a transaction isn't
over when the user pays.
The users may want
to check on, modify,
or reorder an item, which they
can do from the Transaction
History view, accessible
in the Google Assistant.
Finally, we built a new
Order Updates feature
that we're currently
testing in the US
to make it easier for users
to reengage with your app.
You'll be able to send
status updates to users
asynchronously, like when a
car arrives to pick them up
or their food is delivered.
But none of this really
matters if people
can't discover your app.
At I/O, we began
rolling out a new app
directory that will
come to Europe, along
with the Google Assistant.
Accessible from
within the Assistant,
it not only has categories
and user ratings,
it also allows users to
try your app directly
from the Directory page.
Users can create a shortcut
for your app for an easy way
to invoke it.
For example, instead
of saying, OK,
Google, ask
Forecaster Joe what's
the surf report for
the Outer Banks,
you can just say, OK,
Google, is the surf up?
And to make finding
your app easier,
the Assistant is also
learning from the directory
and from the information
provided by you, the developer.
Thanks to these signals,
the Assistant can often
respond to general requests,
like "play a game,"
with a few different
options from third parties.
Improving discovery is
very important for us.
So you can expect ongoing
investment and improvements
in this area.
It is also important to us
that the developer process
is smooth.
That's why at I/O, we launched
a new developer console.
The Actions console
helps you work as a team
and collect data on your
app's usage, performance,
and user discovery patterns.
It is integrated
with the Firebase
and Google Cloud consoles
so that you can share
your data within your apps.
In addition to
the console, we're
also providing you with
access to developer tools
that allow you to
quickly and easily build
apps for the Assistant.
Since the launch
of our platform,
we've worked with an expanding
number of developer tool
companies to make
their solutions
compatible with
Actions on Google.
We've also expanded
the capabilities
of api.ai, our own
conversation building tool,
launching new features
such as follow-up
intense, pre-built agents,
and in-dialogue analytics.
While we are still in the
early days of the platform,
we are focused on
making it more robust
and expanding its reach
and its capabilities.
We recently launched in
UK and Australian English.
And we'll launch the
platform in French, German,
and other languages
following this year.
We're super excited
for the road ahead.
And we want more
of you to join us
by developing for the platform.
With an addressable audience of
more than 100 million devices,
new capabilities
like transactions,
and an improved
developer experience,
we think this is an incredible
opportunity for all of us.
Now the magic of
the Assistant is
enabled by Google's deep
investment in AI and the Cloud.
So to tell you more about how
you can use it directly, please
welcome Sara.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks, Tilke.
I'm incredibly
excited to tell you
everything we're working on
related to machine learning.
My name is Sara Robinson.
I'm a developer advocate on
Google's Cloud Platform team,
focused on big data
and machine learning.
In today's world, any time we
see the words "ML" on a slide,
it always gets a lot
of people's attention.
But before we dive
into the details,
I want to talk about what
machine learning actually is.
At a high level,
machine learning
involves teaching computers
to recognize patterns
in the same way
that our brains do.
Over time, as machine learning
models are given more examples
and experience, they
can improve and start
to generalize on examples
that they haven't seen before.
With more data, they're able
to generate better predictions.
Does anybody remember how they
learned their first language?
Your parents probably
didn't give you a dictionary
and a bunch of grammar books.
That would be weird.
Instead, you learned
over time, after being
exposed to many examples.
So for example, if you
had pierogies for dinner--
since we're in Poland--
you saw them on your plate.
You heard your
parents identify them.
And over time, this strengthened
certain pathways in your brain
so that the next time
you had them for dinner,
it triggered the
part of your brain
that told you, that's a pierogi.
And that's roughly how
machine learning works, too.
To summarize, machine
learning is loosely based
on how the human brain learns,
with mathematical neurons that
mimic the neurons in our brain.
These neurons take
a vector as input,
transform those values,
and then output new values.
And machine learning models
let you solve problems
without requiring you to know
exactly what the solution might
be.
And again, as I
mentioned before,
with more and more
data, these systems
are able to generate
better predictions.
Now many people see the
term "machine learning"
and immediately think it's
something solely for experts.
If we take a look
back 60 years ago,
this was definitely the case.
This is a picture
of the Perceptron,
the first neural network,
invented in 1957.
It was an electronic device
that demonstrated the ability
to identify shapes.
Back then, if you wanted to
work on machine learning,
you needed access to extensive
academic and computing
resources.
Let's fast forward to today.
At Google, even just
since 2012, the number
of products using
machine learning
has grown dramatically.
But at Google, we don't
think machine learning should
be something just for experts.
We want to put machine learning
into the hands of every
developer and data scientist--
that's all of you--
with a computer and a
machine learning problem
they want to solve.
On Google Cloud Platform,
we've got two ways
to help you integrate ML
into your own applications.
First, if you're new
to machine learning,
we have six pre-trained
APIs to give you
access to machine learning
models with a single REST API
request.
And second, if you want
to use your own data
to build and train a
model from scratch,
we have a variety of tools
to help you do that as well.
Let's start with these
pre-trained APIs.
We have a growing
number of models
that have already been
trained and are continuously
being updated using Google's own
domain expertise and data sets.
For example, the Speech API
lets developers implement
speech-to-text
transcription functionality
into their own applications,
similar to OK Google.
I'm going to talk
about all of these APIs
in detail later today
during my breakout session.
So for now, I want to give you
a demo of just one of them.
I'm going to pick one at random.
I'm going to go with the Vision
API, which lets developers
better understand their images.
You can try out all of our
machine learning APIs directly
in the browser using your own
images, text, or video content.
So here, I can upload
an image and see
what the Vision API responds.
So if I click on this, I'm
going to choose a selfie that I
took yesterday in Krakow.
It's a little silly.
We're going to see what
the Vision API responds.
So we can see that it's
able to identify landmarks.
Landmark detection is one of
the features of the Vision API.
It knows the name
of the building
I'm standing in
front of, and it also
is able to identify
Main Market Square.
The face detection
endpoint identifies my face
in the image.
And it's also able to identify
the emotions joy and surprise.
I won't go over all of the
response types in the browser.
But you can all try this out
with your own images if you go
to cloud.google.com/vision.
So we've seen the
machine learning
APIs used across a
variety of industries
to accomplish common
machine learning tasks,
like classifying
images, identifying
inappropriate content,
extracting subjects from a text
document, and more.
But many of you
may have use cases
that go beyond these common
machine learning tasks.
If you want to build ML models
trained on your own data
to perform custom tasks,
we've got products
to help you do that as well.
We know that data is at the
core of any machine learning
problem.
And you need a foundation
of good data to get started.
So in order to help
you prepare your data,
we have tools to help ingest,
transform, clean, and store
your data on Google
Cloud Platform.
Once your data is ready, you
can train, deploy, and serve
your models at scale on
managed Google infrastructure.
In addition to all of
this, the Google Brain team
has provided an open source
library called TensorFlow.
>From the beginning, we
wanted to let everyone
in the industry benefit.
So we made TensorFlow an open
source project on GitHub.
And the uptake has
been phenomenal.
TensorFlow is the most
popular ML project on GitHub,
with over 68,000 GitHub
stars and contributions
coming from many different
companies, not just Google.
To give you a taste of what's
possible with TensorFlow,
I want to show you
TensorFlow Playground,
a visualization of a neural
network in the browser.
So the data set we're
working with here
is called Double Spiral.
And the data here could
really be anything.
We're just classifying it
into one of two categories.
So let's say here we're
working with email data
that we're classifying as
either spam or not spam.
So the orange dots
would indicate spam.
The blue dots would
indicate not spam.
And as humans, if we
take a new data point--
let's say we have a
data point right here--
we can almost immediately
classify that as spam,
as an orange dot.
But it's much more difficult
to teach a computer
these underlying patterns.
And before we start training,
our neural networks predictions
don't make too much sense.
The background
color here indicates
the output or the
prediction of the network.
So we can see here
that most orange dots
are being classified as blue.
So if we start training, we
can see that slowly, our loss--
or error of our model--
is decreasing.
And it's able to identify
some complex patterns
in our dataset.
If we look at each
individual neuron,
we see that they're performing
very simple classification
tasks.
But as we move
through the network,
it's slowly able to
identify complex patterns
in our dataset.
And with more and
more training, we
can see that it's able to
identify this double spiral
pattern.
So we see that as we
went through training,
our loss decreased.
The accuracy of our
model increased.
And now it's able to classify
almost all of the points
in our data set correctly.
I encourage all of
you to try this out
at playground.tensorflow.org.
And in addition to being
a powerful framework,
TensorFlow is designed to
be able to run anywhere.
You can not only run
TensorFlow models
on our fully managed
Cloud ML Engine,
you can run them on
your own servers,
in your own data centers, on
VMs and other cloud providers.
And you can even compile
them down to ARM code
and run them on mobile devices.
If you want to utilize
Google's infrastructure
to ingest data,
train your model,
and run predictions at scale,
we have Cloud Machine Learning
Engine.
To use it, all you need to do
is prepare your training data
in Google Cloud
Storage or BigQuery,
write your TensorFlow
code locally, and then use
the Google Cloud CLI to
run training and prediction
jobs on ML Engine.
And for compute-expensive
tasks like training a model,
ML Engine supports
GPUs, which lets
you significantly accelerate
your machine learning
workloads.
You can go to this URL to
learn more about ML Engine.
And there's one more thing
I'd like to share with you.
One thing we know
to be true at Google
is that great software shines
brightest with great hardware
underneath.
That's why we started a
project at Google several years
ago to see what we could
accomplish with our own custom
accelerators for machine
learning applications.
And the result was a Tensor
Processing Unit, or TPU, which
we announced earlier
this year at Google I/O.
The TPU is a custom chip
we built specifically
for machine learning and
tailored for TensorFlow.
We've been running TPUs
inside our data centers
for more than a
year, and we've found
them to deliver an order of
magnitude better performance
per watt for machine learning.
TPUs are currently in alpha.
If you want to sign
up, you can head over
to cloud.google.com/tpu.
And finally, if you
remember just one thing
from this presentation, remember
that our goal on Google Cloud
Platform is to democratize
machine learning.
We want to make it accessible
not only to ML experts
but to developers
and data scientists.
That's all of you.
Thank you.
Now I'd like to
hand it over to Tal
to talk about the
latest in mobile web.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TAL OPPENHEIMER: Thanks, Sara.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Tal, from
the Chrome team.
And I'm excited to
tell you about some
of the great
improvements we've made
on the web over the last year.
The web is big.
With over 2 billion
instances of Chrome,
we know that the web
has tremendous reach.
But one of the true
strengths of the web
is that it's bigger
than a single browser.
So regardless of
whether a device
is a smartphone or a
laptop or a desktop,
they all have a browser.
So any web-based experience
is available on these billions
of devices today.
And we've seen this have a
real impact on how many users
web apps are reaching.
We've all seen how quickly
mobile has been growing.
And native apps
have been growing
at an incredible pace with it.
But what's really remarkable
is that even with the web's
large initial reach, we've
seen the average monthly web
audience growing even faster.
And because of
this growth, we're
seeing the web expand
into new areas,
with experiences
like web VR being
built on the web platform.
And the web continues to pop
up in more and more places,
even some you might not expect.
We now see the web popping up on
watches, TVs, or even fridges.
So with the web pretty
much everywhere,
we're constantly trying
to push the boundaries
on what it can actually do.
Over the past
year, we've shipped
hundreds of additional APIs that
cover a range of capabilities,
from making it easy to
integrate payments into your web
experience to making
it possible to build
fully capable offline
media experiences directly
on the web.
And with all of these
new experiences,
we've seen a massive growth in
experiences built on the web.
Accelerated Mobile
Pages, or AMP,
allows publishers to easily
create fast articles.
And since launch, we've seen
this grow to over 2 billion AMP
pages across 900,000 domains.
And beyond AMP pages,
the modern mobile web
also allows developers to
build rich mobile experiences
with something that we call
Progressive Web Apps, or PWAs.
PWAs are about helping
web developers leverage
the web's reach with
new capabilities
to build high-class,
immersive experiences.
They can load quickly.
They work offline.
And they can even send
notifications to users.
And we've seen a number of
amazing experiences taking
advantage of these
new capabilities.
As just one example,
Twitter recently
launched a new web experience.
Here, they have a polished,
fast, immersive experience
that works on any connection and
can send users notifications.
And since it's built
completely on the web platform,
it's already accessible
on billions of devices.
And with an immersive
experience like this,
we also want to make sure that
it's really easy for users
to get back to it.
Add to Homescreen has
existed for some time
and allows users to add any
experience to their Android
home screen.
But with our improved
Add to Homescreen
flow, when you add a
PWA to your homescreen,
it's fully integrated
into the platform
so that to users it feels
just like any other app
experience on their device.
It'll appear in the
Android Launcher
alongside your other
apps, and it'll even
appear in Android Settings.
But since it's a PWA,
it's inherently small.
So users are able to get
an immersive experience
without requiring
additional storage space.
And this fast,
integrated, improved Add
to Homescreen experience
is available now.
With all of these
new capabilities,
we've also been
working to make sure
that it's super easy
for web developers
to build these experiences.
We'll be going into a lot
more detail about PWAs
throughout the web track
over the next two days,
but no matter how you're
building your web app,
Lighthouse is a tool
that can show you
how to improve your experience.
Lighthouse is a Chrome
extension and command line
tool that quickly
audits your site
to identify how you
can improve your app's
performance, accessibility,
and progressive web appiness.
And we're excited to announce
that as of M60, Lighthouse
is now integrated
into Chrome DevTools.
So now, you can quickly see
how your website is doing
and what to do next
directly in Chrome.
With all of these
tools, we've seen just
how easy it can be
for companies to take
advantage of these new
capabilities for their web
experience.
To give one example, there's
Trivago, a popular hotel
comparison site that recently
built a very polished PWA.
It's an experience built
directly on the web,
so users can get to it easily.
And with our new Add
to Homescreen flow,
it can be easily accessed from
the App Launcher or the Android
homescreen.
And when you open it, you
get a high-class, immersive
experience that can even
work if you're offline and is
built to be resilient against
different network conditions.
So you get a seamless experience
when you go back online.
But what's really incredible is
that this entire PWA experience
was built by three
core engineers
in just a couple of months.
And this is just
one example of many.
Leveraging the modern
mobile web is now
the norm around the world.
Whether you're building
a PWA from scratch
or leveraging the
latest capabilities
on your existing web
experience, companies everywhere
are seeing a tangible
impact on their key metrics.
With the modern mobile web,
it's possible to easily build
immersive, fully
capable experiences that
can reach billions of people
around the world today.
And now, let's turn
our focus to what
we're doing to make it
easier to develop apps
and grow your business.
Please welcome Francis.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCIS MA: Thanks, Tal.
Hi, I'm Francis.
And I lead the
Firebase Product team.
Our mission is to help
developers build a better app
and grow a successful business.
Since I/O 2016, we've
expanded Firebase
from a set of back-end services
to a broad mobile platform
to help solve many of
the common problems
you face across the
lifecycle of an app,
from helping you build faster
and easier with products
like real-time database
and Cloud storage,
to helping you better
understand and grow your app
with tools like Analytics
and Cloud Messaging.
Whether you're
starting something new
or looking to extend
an existing app,
we're here to help
you so that you
can channel more of
your time and energy
towards creating
value for your users.
And we deliver all of this
in a single, easy-to-use SDK
available across platforms.
To date, there are over
1 million developers
using Firebase.
And we're humbled
so many of you have
taken this journey with us.
We're deeply
committed to Firebase,
and we're doubling
down on our efforts
to help developers succeed.
On that note,
earlier this year, we
were excited to have the
Fabric team join us at Google.
Since launching
Crashlytics at 2011,
our teams have shared
a very similar mission.
And now, we're working together
to integrate our two platforms
and bring you the best of
both in a thoughtful way.
One of the first
steps we're taking
is to bring
Crashlytics to Firebase
to make that our flagship
crash-reporting product.
If you're an existing customer
of Fabric or Firebase,
we're going to be paving a
smooth transition path for you
over the coming months.
We've also been working
closely with the Digits team
to bring the next evolution
of phone-number sign-in
to Firebase authentication.
With it, you can
extend your app,
enable users to sign
in with a phone number.
They just need to do a one-time
verification, and they're in.
With Firebase Auth,
we also provide
a headless API so that
you can have full control
and customize the UI to fit
the look and feel of your app.
In addition to
integrating with Fabric,
we've also made many
updates over the last year.
And I'd like to highlight
a few of these for you.
One of our goals at
Firebase is to save you
from managing servers
so that you can
focus on building great apps.
And to help with
this, we've released
Cloud Functions for Firebase.
With Cloud Functions,
you can deploy
JavaScript code to
the Cloud and have
that triggered based
on an HTTP request
or with other events
happening across Firebase.
For example, you can set up
a function with Firebase Auth
to automatically send a push
notification through FCM
when a new user signs
up or, say, set up
a function with
storage so that you
can do some
service-side processing,
like machine learning, when
a new image is uploaded.
Or you can also use
Functions with Hosting
to create a fully dynamic
website without managing
any servers.
Functions is a great
way to extend your app
and enables true
serverless development.
So we just talked
about how Firebase
helps you build more easily.
Let's switch gears
to talk about how
it can help you build
better and really
focus on your app quality.
Now as developers, we
spend a lot of time
optimizing and testing our apps.
But when we release
our apps in the wild,
sometimes end users experience
something entirely different
based on the diversity of
devices or network conditions.
And when our apps
don't perform well,
it's frustrating for everyone.
And that's why we've
released Firebase Performance
Monitoring.
You can add
Performance Monitoring
with one line of code,
and it will automatically
measure your app's startup
time and network latency.
You can then also add
additional custom traces
to measure the timing across at
different points in your app.
You can drill in
deeper to filter
your data based on the country,
app version, or device type
to get a sense of how users are
really experiencing your app
and not just on
your office Wi-Fi.
Performance Monitoring is a
nice compliment to Crashlytics
and Analytics to help you
better understand and find
those bottlenecks that
could be impacting
your user engagement or even
your business bottom line.
Speaking of Analytics, we've
also made a number of updates
on this front.
Earlier in the year, we
released StreamView to give you
a real-time view of how
users are interacting
with your app across the world.
We've also added custom
parameter reporting
to give you the next
level of insights,
in addition to the
events that you logged.
For example, let's
say that you log
the events that are
happening when a user pass
a round in your game.
Now you can also get reports
to the custom parameters,
like the type of
game that was played
or the average number of
coins they were awarded.
We've also worked
with the AdMob team
to give you insights
to which ad on which
screen are earning you the most
so that you can really optimize
both your ad revenue, along
with your user engagement,
with the broader Analytics
insights that you get.
We've also enhanced
our experience
with BigQuery, where you
can export your Analytics
events in raw, join it
with custom data sets,
and perform ad hoc analysis.
It's super powerful.
With BigQuery, you can
also use it with DataStudio
to create your own custom
visualizations and reports.
Essentially, you can
build your own analytics
UI the way you need.
In addition to
building features,
we've also recently
launched a Firebase Alpha
Program that gives access
to unreleased products.
And this is a great opportunity
to provide early feedback
and help shape Firebase.
Incorporating customer feedback
is a key part of our product
development process.
And we look forward to hearing
from developers like you.
Just sign up at the URL.
Now we just shared
some of the updates
we've made since last year.
To learn even more and here
where we've been up to,
we'll be hosting the Firebase
Dev Summit in Amsterdam
at the end of October.
You can learn more about the
event a firebase.google.com,
and I look forward to
see many of you there.
I look forward to
hearing your feedback
and continue to work hard to
help you build a better app
and grow a more
successful business.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And now I'd like to
bring Jason back on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON TITUS: Thanks, Francis.
As you can see, we're
continuing to work
hard to improve the developer
experience for Google's
products.
Tomorrow morning,
you'll hear more
about the products our
engineering teams at Google
are building here in
Europe, whether it's
our Compression
team in Switzerland,
amazing compiler and
language work in Denmark,
or our Cloud team in Poland
that's scaling the cloud.
You'll also have the
opportunity to dive
deep into a number
of our products
covering Android to
Firebase to the mobile web.
We'll have Sandboxes to help you
experience products firsthand,
instructor-led
trainings and Code Labs
to get you trained and running
on our latest APIs today.
In addition to all of this, we
have a large number of Googlers
who are available for
one-on-one consultations
through office hours.
Not only can they help you
understand our products,
but more importantly, they're
here to get your feedback.
I do have one other thing to
mention before you head out
to the breakout sessions today.
Last year, we
partnered with Udacity
to provide 10,000
Android scholarships
to European developers.
And we were overwhelmed by
the demand for the scholarship
and were truly amazed by
some of the stories that
came out of it.
Let's take a look
at Ildiko's story,
a former literature
teacher turned coder.
Play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JASON TITUS: So
Ildiko's story is
just one of many that motivates
us to continue programs
like this.
That's why today I'm excited to
announce that we're extending
our partnership with Udacity to
begin the Udacity Scholarship
Challenge, this time with
enough space for 60,000
aspiring developers
across Europe
and select parts of AMEA.
[APPLAUSE]
And we're also
expanding the scope
to include both Android
and mobile web development.
So please visit the website
to sign up and learn more.
[APPLAUSE]
So as you heard from
the speakers today,
we're really excited
about the possibilities
for developers to build
some truly amazing things.
We're looking forward to getting
to know you over the next two
days and hear
what's on your mind.
Thank you, and have fun.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]